Pois é. Você sabia que um energético
pode te mandar direto pro hospital? Olha
só o que aconteceu com o Rafael Zulu. O
cara tomou 2,5 L de energético com gin
no único dia. Resultado, parou no
hospital com coração descompassado, uma
fibrilação atrial. Isso é sério, viu?
Pode dar AVC, trombose. O zulu ficou 4
dias internado. Veja bem, um energético
tem em média 80 mg de cafeína. Em 2,5 L.
São quase 800 mg. É como tomar 10
xícaras de café expresso de uma vez.
Agora, adiciona álcool nessa mistura. A
cafeína mascara o efeito do álcool, você
bebe mais sem perceber e o coração fica
doidão batendo fora do ritmo. Então fica
a dica. Energético não é suco. Se for
beber vai com calma e misturar com
álcool. Péssima ideia.